right everybody
we'll get started thank you
that sounds better
i've got my technician here
right welcome everybody um just remind
everybody that the meeting has been
recorded
it was going to be live stream but it's
like
connectivity issues
but it will be um online tomorrow
morning
so i would just remind you that it is
being recorded so
please just be mindful of that as usual
right i'll kick off with apologies
everybody's here nothing from there any
conflicts of interest to declare
right the confirmation of the last
minutes
anybody want to move that those be
accepted thank you phillip do i have a
secondary
thank you mark any discussion around
those
andrea madam chair just
just a minor adjustment to um
6.1 the second paragraph
from me was just to
basically identify as this of the school
run we know what it was
spoken of but the school bus run maybe
just to a little thing
i don't know
[Music]
okay yeah thank you
right any other discussion from anyone
but i'll put the emotion with that
slight amendment uh
to the vote all those in favor say line
those against
that's carried any matters arising from
those minutes
[Music]
all right we've got a dictation from
paul from the
secton hall committee and some of the
we've got four members of the sefton
hall committee here so
please welcome come to the table and
talk to us
and thank you very much for all coming
should we all go good evening
everybody thank you very much for
letting us
um attend this meeting tonight and um
just
update update everyone where we're
actually up to
with the hall itself it's been an
ongoing
um things since the two earthquakes
um 2010 2012.
um the hall itself sustained quite a bit
of
external cracking through the block work
and a bit of structural damage inside
we never actually got the our insurance
company into
2013 possibly due to
they were going in all directions with
other you know other problems around
canterbury
so um once they finally come out here
and
we sort of talked about what was going
to happen
they said that they need to have a
detailed engineering report done on the
hall
so it was to do with the
finance side of it if it was going to be
below their their payout cap
of 300 000 they would have paid to
get the repairs done and that would have
been sorted
but the engineering report come back at
well over that so they quickly give us a
cheat for 300
000 and run away so
from then on we've sort of been
getting prices of how much actually it's
going to cost to repair it
that sort of grew
grew up to probably near around 700
000 that's just to bring it up to the
68 of the detailed
um evaluation um
at present the council's given us an
evaluation of 37
so we're sort of right down to the
minimum
so at this stage we thought it's another
two or three years slipped by
and then we decided to call a community
meeting last year
just to let everyone know what's
happening and
try and get some direction from
sefton community itself
at that meeting it was we had a good
turnout
and there was quite a few things kicked
around
and we finished up deciding to do a
feasibility study
on the community just to see where we
stood
if we wanted to repair the hall
rebuild the hall on site or rebuild the
hall
in another site and and safety
so this study was started early
march last year it was completed just
before
christmas and then over christmas time
nothing happened then we come into that
time when covert 19 decided to rear its
ugly face so
we we couldn't do anything for those few
months
so we called another public meeting as
soon as we could
so that would have been a couple of
months ago
the company that uh
that actually did the feasibility study
actually come and presented it to the
community
and um just
it really showed everyone how the
population
sits now and sort of for the future
the school and everything
basically had everything that you'd want
to know about the area
so it was it was brilliant um we took a
vote at the end
of what to do with the hall and it was
pretty close but it was
pretty much everyone was we needed to
build a new hall
it was a lot of money to invest in the
old hall
it looks pretty good pretty tidy
but internally removing all the block
work
doing the repair repairs under the floor
and all that
sort of thing the money was just gonna
it was just
getting out of control so
both builders that we had that um give
us a price
were around that seven hundred possibly
more they said
both of them said it wasn't worth doing
two
there was too many unknown
parts to the structure also
it's possibility would have had to
update the
sewage system which would have put
another 100
000 on top of it so
to do the repairs and what money we had
in the bank
we would have probably had to raise
about a half a million dollars
so we decided well if we just
take the insurance money of 300 000
if we could sell the whole two sections
and at a local library
and put all the money together we could
end up with
possibly seven to eight hundred thousand
dollars
so we still to build a new hall
up in the domain we're looking at about
1.3
so we still have to raise a half million
dollars
so it was either we raised a half
million to repair the old hall
or we cash everything in
and go for a new hall bring it
completely up to standard
so at this stage at our
last meeting we asked
grant to come along just give us a bit
of a info on
where the council stands up in the
domain
and whether that is possible for us to
do it
so it was really good meeting um he
basically gave us everything we wanted
to know
so straight after that we had a vote
and the committee decided well let's
just go for it
we'll go for the new hall so that's
where we are at this stage
so it's all really up to grant's
crew and what happens here now
whether we can proceed with it
so it's pretty pretty quick
thanks for that paul um questions
from anyone um also around the library
the old library how's the sale of that
going for the sorting out of that one
denise might they want to give us a bit
of a update on that has been transferred
to the new trustees
but um is still currently working on the
trust
side of it that can be dissolved yep so
we're
not a lot further ahead than we were a
few years ago either
is
i missed the public meeting but i was
aware that there was a discussion
about the interaction of the hall with
the school
i just wonder that often it's not an
unusual discussion to
to come up i just wonder where that has
got to what conclusion was reached on
that regard
[Music]
yes definitely a lot of um
lot of talk from the school they were
worried about losing their car parking
area out the front of the hall
and that sort of thing and not so much
about
there was a wee bit talked about the
location of the
call now versus taking it up to the
demand
but um really it just come down to
like the number of times the school uses
versus the community use of the hall
yeah
and you know the the feeling was
against um moving the hall
but yeah
there was no one put their hand up to
give us a hand or
do anything so we've just moved forward
with the feasibility study which i think
that's the best
for the community in the future
[Music]
sorry paul it's not a question for you
but i just wondered if denise
are there any hold-ups worth sorting out
the trust
that i haven't heard from you for a wee
while that time
well that sounds like you're making
progress so that's a good thing
paul could i just ask
how public is the decision
it's stuck at this stage we haven't let
anything
out there maybe just a wee bit of talk
in the background
but we're just waiting to hear back from
the council
and um just just to see whether that
can happen up in the domain if that if
it can't
we have to rethink the situation here
another thing going up to the domain it
allows us to use the whole
here until the one up in the domain will
be finished
that could be a wee time depending on
raising funds and
getting set up for it
but we didn't really have a um
a lot of people sort of against going
up to the domain there was more voiced
about
car park issues around there and
yeah i think it's in general at the
school
[Music]
paul another question what is the ideal
time frame do you have an ideal time
frame of
when you see it
[Music]
no we really haven't sort of
gone down that line as yet um
there's a few more hoops and hurdles to
go through and then
i always suspect after christmas we'll
be looking at setting up a
a timeline to raising funds and
getting drawings done and actually
moving on
i would say it'll be it'll be a next
within the next two years
miss plenty of time
um are you going to put in an
application to the council for
long under the long-term plan for
funding
definitely yes um
there'll be several other avenues we've
got to try and sue
same time so it'll be depending on what
funds we can
just get locally and from the council
and from other new zealand groups that
will approach
um well paul was probably more of a
statement than a question
um i think it's really important um when
you outset out and approach your carcass
to have a concept in front of you can
show people
and therefore it makes fundraising a lot
easier
because people can see something
concrete in front of them
you know what i'm talking about is a
concept plan
so once that concept plan is out from
the
community people can see it what's going
to
happen it doesn't it's not a final thing
at least it's a sort of bullseye that
people can name it
you know that's just a comment
with the feasibility study they did a
concept plan
of the all actually up in the domain
that was just to get a costing a rough
costing
it's probably not going to suit most or
some of the clubs up they use the domain
so
it's just a matter of working with the
clubs
and then hiring somebody to do some
drawings and that
we really just need to know which
direction
we're going to go first before we take
that
first step
[Music]
paul i may suggest you've actually made
the first step in a way by
saying there rather than here i think
that's probably quite
significant and quite positive you know
yes i think um it was a pretty close one
in the end but at the end of the day
it's
looking to the future of sefton i'm
pretty sure
the committee is behind us and saying
that i'm hopefully
i'm hoping it'll lift the community and
get everyone in behind it
so that's probably our second step
of that is getting the clubs together
everyone who will use the hall and see
what they want
and then get a drawing done and go from
there
paul apart from our support which i
can't speak for everyone else but fully
from
i know the members that have been to
your meetings what else do you need
from us as a community board
once we've had the okay from the council
that we can
build up in the domain the community
board to
just if they can just get behind us
and maybe publicize it a wee bit for us
in the community just really get behind
us that's all we need
thank you paul any other questions
i mean on behalf of the community world
i'd like to say
good on you for getting to this point
making a decision i know it has been a
journey
[Music]
but great to hear that a decision has
been made
and certainly the community board
i mean as andrea said the members many
of us have
come to public meetings here um come to
your meetings you know and talked with
you
so yes there is a high degree of support
from us in general
[Music]
i would also like to say thank you to
the hall committee
[Music]
um
you've done amazingly well it has been
difficult
it has taken time but
you've followed a process you've
consulted with the community
you've made a decision and i would also
have to say
that yes would you say the hall looks
okay this current hall looks okay
and to be honest that is down to the
whole committee
in particular the custodian for the way
the hall is actually managed so
i would say very well done for that so
we will be following with interest and
i'm sure we'll be pushing
um the community and green space team
along occasionally and thank you very
much
[Music]
cool i'd just like to thank
dan for coming along to that meeting
earlier on here
and that sort of give us some um
support from the council he said
basically said
either direction we go that they would
help us out
then grant coming along
and actually clarifying a few things at
the meeting
and the support from the community board
all the way through it's been brilliant
thank you
[Music]
madam chair to move that we actually
request from staff and take a grant that
the report that it comes back to the
sefton
hall committee is actually shared at
community board level
please
sorry you're all very welcome to stay
for
the meeting uh actually i forgot at the
beginning of the meeting there is one
correction
in the
[Music]
at the end of the meeting sorry it is
so just to clarify that better
any adjoining business
i'm uh forever apologizing that it's not
grant stephens but it's me
um same again um
so yeah look basically with this
report that the members would have got
the local lions club has come forward
they're keen to put some seats
actually within what is the wooden
community centre
reserve so you can see that on the
attached plan there there's a couple of
proposed seats plus there's also a
proposed sign
the reason that the seats are angled the
way that they are is actually because
it's taken into account the ceremonies
and so forth that occur there
so that's why they're on opposing sides
like that because it allows a little bit
of flexibility for the space
the lions club themselves have actually
raised the funds for this so it's cost
neutral in terms of
capex it's a small operational cost for
us to add it into our asset base but
it's not significant
in any way one of the
i guess other things for the board to
consider within this report as well is
that there is
a potential for a sign to go in so the
club have suggested that they would like
a sign
there is no funding for that there's
certainly nothing that we can identify
within green space budgets to
pay for that so if it was something that
the board were keen on
it would have to come from the general
landscaping budget
just with that as well it's also worth
noting that the
the naming of the
[Music]
the sign itself it would really have to
say wooden war memorial
because it is actually on a vested
reserve so we couldn't turn around and
call it
a different reserve name we'd actually
have to go through a subdivision and
classification process to do that and
then also
rename it so that's quite a complicated
and quite a long process to do
and that's really as to whether or not
the board wants to support the sign
going in
so look i'm happy to take questions at
this point on that
[Music]
um grant the location of the seats
but you know
what is the reason for them being with
their own
so they were chosen in conjunction with
the lions club
um so they were chosen in conjunction
with the lions club but also they wanted
to put them on opposing sides so that we
had as much flexibility in the space for
ceremonies because they still run a
number of ceremonies down there most
notably on anzac day as well
so the seats being where they are that
was the idea plus also
if they did end up with a sign they
didn't want to clutter that
front area there next to school road as
well so that's some of the primary
thinking
um from my professional background
the seats there's a congregation area on
the opening for anzac day is actually
quite compromised
um already and i've so
um i don't believe the seat should be
located further away
from the memorial um
to actually keep an open space around
the memorial for people to congregate on
and so the idea of receipts being moved
further back
in more of a meditation type of area
than rather than looking at
the signs themselves you know and get up
and
stand up and look at them um
anyway that's that um what i'm asking
you is that
is the position of those seats a
mandatory thing
or are they open to suggestion
we could go back to the club and talk
them through if the board wanted to move
the location of the seats
we could certainly go back to the club
and talk to them about the seat location
if that was a sticking point
that'd be great because i had a meeting
with mr lenny because i'm part of the
lions too
um i had a meeting with mr lenny and he
um he sort of agreed that they probably
should be moved further out from the
memorial um and
for a total reason what i'm saying you
know and we need to
we need as much clean space around that
memorial for
people to gather them anyway
what i was going to propose um
that it was part of my background and as
part of the lines i was going to prepare
a sort of
a basic landscape concept
with with some pictures of what it could
look like
and how with the seats where they are
where they could be located
is that is that okay
around the district does anyone else
have a sign
generally not a bespoke sign that's
individual
to it um it's normally quite intuitive
as to whether or not there's
a war memorial there or it might
actually be named as a reserve
as part of the war memorial this one is
within the wooden community centre
reserve
so it doesn't specifically have a sign
but the interpretation is part of the
feature if that makes sense
[Music]
ah thank you grant has the rsa
been consulted about the location of the
seats
since they're generally the organisation
that runs events such as anzac day
i would have to double check that with
grant sorry that's not one of the
questions that i asked with him but i
can certainly get back on that point
um i would be surprised if he hasn't had
some form of conversation with them
because they're normally uh quite in
sync with the lions club themselves
they certainly have been for the first
part of the project which was the
putting up of the
um the feature there
just one moment um john in the question
i know that
grunt had quite a conversation in many
because i was copied in
to the email around location and they
discussed it by email and read on this
one
there is also a time factor in terms of
i know
that the wooden lions want the seats
[Music]
so i'm not sure delaying
placement of the seats for the
livestream
um i don't think it matters the woody
and community association
are going to install these seats so
where they put them it doesn't really
matter does it
you know we can actually put a plan as
long as it's
an idea um the seats can go in anyway
doesn't matter where we put them
they're going to hold it up that won't
hold it up and actually effect
anyway
that is whatsoever the seats are
installed in the
position as indicated and
also that if
if the lines club wants to see people
um sign
[Music]
um
[Applause]
abc
would you be prepared to concern the
ending
um
the wooden community association are
prepared to organise the installation
approving the installation indicated on
the attached plan
[Music]
um
is
[Music]
so that is
see you next time
um my reasoning is
is that that had been discussed within
from the woody
lions the wooden lions have said you
know they really want
sexist arms armistice day
so i'm happy to go with that i think the
placement the logic behind that
placement
when i read the emails was good
i also believe that
putting money in towards a sign for a
memorial
memorial is not warranted and i
cannot justify to the community
spending money on installing science
saying
putting
[Music]
thank you madam chair um i'm the same
and
the reason for my question to grant was
about is there any other signs
with war morals and as you said it's
very significant
any war memorial but also to the money
as we know in 2019 we actually
gave five thousand dollars to the warm
world which i think was significant
and likewise we need to share as spend
with the rest of the community so i
fully support
madam chair's motion thank you
madam chair i'd like to move a very
minor amendment
to clause d
by adding the words subject to the rsa's
approval
that was what i was trying to do earlier
[Music]
well if madam chair if you are happy to
hold your emotion
i'll withdraw them
[Music]
would you like to speak to
i'll just speak in support of the motion
adam chair i'm
happy with the motion as you've now put
it i think it's very sensible
the rsa are one of the main users of
that
area so i think it's appropriate that
they be
consulted over the location of the
seating which may affect how they
organize their events such as anzac day
armistice day and whatever thank you
oh my quite honestly don't i object
completely i like the amendment
and they've made that it's up to the
lions
to decide where these seats go not to be
be rude or anything but i think it's the
lions who have the final decision
there is their park i've talked to lenny
and he
he understood exactly where we're going
he was very happy with the idea
um and so i'm like an amendment
that over the seats will be installed
are going to be installed by the woody
and community association
and i believe that the discretion should
be at the lines
where they go and not for us to sit here
and say
that's where they're going to go you
know
um the whole point of this
i'd like to move an amendment that the
final location of the seats
is designated by the lions you have
woody
[Music]
would you want the rsa approval
is
[Music]
interpreting that d so with the addition
of the
the rsa if they um
as john as indicated wanted
the seats moved that would move them
would it
or are you saying that um
it would need the wood end lines on top
of that
or does the rsa actually have a say in
the
in the sighting of these seats
from what you've got there
[Music]
and determine the location
okay
is
[Music]
can it be with consultation with the
rsa and the lines to to approve
where they think the location is can
that be so the two groups in which they
agree
that's where it goes
if john changes
i'm very happy with the outcome of that
if we are going to agree everyone's
going to agree with
the idea that the lions and their essay
determine the locations of this well put
it this way
consultation with the rsa so they
acknowledge where we're going to go
thank you
thank you i certainly support that i i
do think what john is saying
has merit because the thing that struck
me about that say it is
immediately you get a um a gathering
there
they're going to be even if people are
sitting in those seats there'll be
people standing in front of them
obscuring what's going on
and it makes sense to have them i would
say
at the back but certainly
bringing these two parties in to talk it
through
is an ideal solution as far as i'm
concerned so happy to support it
[Music]
right i'll put that motion does
everybody understand what the motion is
any other speakers to be mended motion
all right i'll put that to the boat all
those in favor say
those against that's carried
thank you
[Applause]
okay
good evening everyone um this report
from
sarah is in connection with basically
just officially putting what we've been
doing for the last
six or seven months
into practice and getting it written off
signed off
so it's to do with changing the standing
orders to take into account
the um the ability
for the board to meet by a technical
means or for one board member to
meet to be included in the meeting
if he is he or she is unable to attend
the meeting
via technical means so
those are really the only major changes
to the standing orders and we're just
looking to update them
as of 12th of october
happy to answer questions if i can
okay i appreciate you can't maybe not
answer this question
if we want to suggest in addition to
standing orders
what is the process around that
[Music]
um the process would be
you can it depends i suppose on how
substantive that
amendment is
[Music]
i don't feel that i could actually word
it immediately
as to how it would read but i can
present the notion for it
whether that is better in a workshop
rather than
through the meeting i take your
advisement jim
thank you i feel would come under
conduct
and it's only because i've been part of
the rewriting of a constitution of late
and it was an addition that we made to
our constitution and i thought
it was timing this right withstanding
order
was that if
any member of a board
is not able to fulfill their role
in the full capacity and with coherence
then they would need to actually be
addressed by either
council or by the chair or both
if they were not performing their role
to what they've been elected for
i think the nature of your
suggestion is one that probably requires
some wider consideration
both in terms of what currently sits in
the local government
um in the local government official
information meetings act so there is
eligibility criteria for remembering
a fairly high threshold over the act for
you know who can't stand or be able to
stand and that's
somewhat in the nature of what you've
talked about it would be your
own capacity which would be quite a test
to
determine so i think it would be
we would want to think quite carefully
about that it's something we'd be happy
to
consider whether the current combination
of acting standing or has enabled that
or whether that should be considered a
standing order and it would be something
that would probably apply to all
that will if it was about that merit
then it would probably apply to wars
rather than just something relatively
minor so
i think it would be beyond the scope of
the proposed change at the moment of
what's proposed at the moment
and would need further consideration
amir has the unfortunate task of sort of
being the board of custodian
portfolio holder of extending orders on
behalf of us all so
term with um i imagine
if the board were absolutely determined
about that then
it's a matter the board could consider
at a later date
the first one on page 38 and the
definition of local authority
does that include a community board
it does under section 5 is it
right on page 63
15.5 um
15.3 sorry time limits it says speakers
can speak for up to 10 minutes
no more than two speakers can speak on
behalf of an organisation's deputation
is that 10 minutes per speaker or 10
minutes in total
for two speakers
it's usually 10 minutes in
the chair always has discretion as to
how
he or she may apply
that during a deportation but it's it's
generally intended to be 10 minutes
otherwise
you end up with a dozen people coming
along
talking for 10 minutes each to reinforce
the same point which
may not be in the meeting's best
interests
right my last question related to page
[Applause]
clause 17.1 code of conduct committee
um this is the only reference to a
code of conduct committee unlike the
council which has
actually appointed a code of conduct
committee
what is envisaged here what is the
composition
of the code of conduct committee
have we got one for the board
and if so who is it and when were they
appointed
or does this clause need a little
further thought
oh sorry so there isn't
a code of conduct committee established
for any of the community boards
if there was a matter to be brought
that felt needed to be brought as a code
of conduct in relation to
the community board it says
should a code of conduct
committee be called which is essentially
it would require a report from us to
establish a code of conduct
committee to hear that matter so the
first thing the board would have to do
is establish a code of conduct committee
appoint a chairperson to it and
to enable it to act including terms of
reference which
we would probably look to use other
terms of reference
that have been developed for the council
most likely
and at that point then
the process would be determined by that
by both the terms of reference and
probably what would be considered
fear due process for the consideration
of a
code of conduct matter
uh what why i asked was several years
ago the kaiapoi to a kiwi community
board i raised the same matter
that if there was a code of conduct
hearing relating to a board member
who should hear it and the answer at
that time was it would be the council
code of conduct committee but it was
felt appropriate that perhaps a
committee of
the board member's peers may be more
appropriate
or certainly at least having the chair
or deputy chair
as part of that committee
[Music]
so the way the terms of reference
the the standing order is currently read
it's a
it's a it would be a committee of the
board
the board could of course um
nominate whoever wished to be on that
committee it doesn't necessarily have to
be board members so it could be
it could be somebody else to hear a
matter if none of the board wanted to
so provided there was agreement from
those who wanted to stand
or be part of that committee and it
could include
other elected members including you know
councillors if that were or council
members if that was felt
appropriate so i think they
are very broad
um and how to how to give effect to it
they are enabling in that regard
so it would be up to the board to decide
how it wanted to manage a code of
conduct i think it's
if it's a matter for the board then it's
really the board to this
to decide how our code of conduct
matters should be resolved
or be it as help it's it may take
advice from whoever it seems appropriate
in
forming that view
so just to be clear the
code of conduct you have a code of
conduct already
and these are the provisions in your
code of conduct what this
what this matter is bringing before you
is a relatively straightforward matter
um to enable um
provisions for meetings during the covet
lockdown or post covert lockdown and how
to deal with that so this is a
relatively small amendment an update to
your existing
code of conduct so it's not a um
this is not a new well it's a new code
of conduct yet because it's being
amended but it's only being amended
rather
rather slightly by what is currently
within the standing orders of the board
uh one last question on page 97
uh just the typo i think
number one after community the word
board has been
omitted
[Applause]
and i understood this is the first time
the board has had its own
specific standing orders in the past
that has used the councils
is that correct i've also raised that in
the past as well
[Music]
that's not my understanding
i think you've been operating
understanding what is off the board
the chair has just presented me with a
obviously a
a a well-thumbed version so that's been
around
that has been around for some time so i
think i think
this board has already adopted standing
waters and i'd be
most surprised
modified as appropriate for community
boards references
to community boards sellers 218 was the
last time the board adopted it thank you
oh i'm tempted to not even ask a
question because one of the
nice things about the community board in
my view is the fact that we um
stick to the rules but we don't get too
hung up with
standing orders but we've had a good guy
tonight i just had a very
simple set of questions when um deep in
the in the paper was the motions and
amendments
like we went through earlier on and
there's some red writing
there is that read writing it's not code
related i don't think it's all this
stuff about
motion moved maximum 10 minutes and then
further relevant amendments to
moved and the rewriting are those
refinements or clarification of what was
there before are they
adding in it's page 89
appendix 3 emotions with amendments and
motions without amendments
i just to understand whether
the background to where the red writing
why it wasn't
was in there because i don't know what
it looked like beforehand
i think they
were changes that so that's probably a
relevant point i think there were
changes that the council
made to provide clarity so that so what
you've got there is a
a a an appendix to help
people understand how to interpret the
standing orders and
there were some questions at the council
about just
just how did that work and so
some of that read was clarity of um
thought about the process and making it
clearer so
they were you're right to note that they
were brought through
from the council and it is a tradition
well spotted
it's quite a good little um i'm not
encouraging anyone to spend any more
time on it but it's quite a good little
summary i thought of
some of this stuff
you can do it next year at that time
essential for these standing orders but
under appendix
by a hilly chuckle when it talked about
um which is all about the webcasting
protocols so we're trying to bring
ourselves into
you know right now and item number four
says powerpoint presentations recording
of votes by division and other matters
displayed by overhead projector may be
shown
for some of us of a certain age
projectors made a very clunky piece of
machinery
presentations or presentations using
technology
just so that it's um it's not confining
itself to powerpoint because who never
who knows microsoft
something other than powerpoint as well
but any other questions
right is somebody happy to
[Music]
move
um
so much community board but maybe
something that we can direct
into this label
when one is elected um
sign so i think we just need to
present this to staff to get some
feedback from them everybody happy with
that
she's raised
[Music]
um i have one addition
to that which is
[Music]
questions around them
did i ask you that we received that
information
thank you andrea
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
[Music]
everything's in there so thank you madam
cheers
to update one item uh
the environment court matter relating to
a
subdivision of woody end which i
referred to somewhere
in my comments on the 14th of september
i had noted the decision was reserved
and the decision has been issued and
the council was successful in
opposing the um plaintiff's
application so it was
round one but a good result for the
council
otherwise i'm happy to answer any
questions if there are any
points i have one
question there was
a report at the last council meeting
around a plane challenge
for private change for ravenswood
um could could we have an update on how
that
loans that progression um
and was put to the council in october
and the
council um approved the plan change for
notification too so
it will be notif it takes a wee while
from that point to then get it to the
point of public notification but yes
there will be
public notification of that plan change
you've got anything you'd like to
just a couple of things one of which i'd
like your advisement and chair
on it but uh i'd just
like to know those bus route changes
have taken effect i mean
see those certain like the waiku beach
service has been cut
back am i is this appropriate um heading
to
make a comment about this
and if not there were two matters of the
sort of nature that i
was a bit confused about what i should
say or asked
i've got a question to ask
i just just noted we've got a forum
session afterwards and i do see joey
here so they might it might be best to
deal with that at that time if that's
okay
nothing else to add
a clear couple of items um as you may
already know plan change
seven to the canterbury land and water
regional plan
which attracted 550 odd submissions
um it's the hearings have started
and they are every other week up until
december
um and the advice it's an e-cam
plan change of course and um the advice
the legal advice
to ecan from its council is that the nps
the new nps
fresh water and then es
rules are to be given legal effect too
in this plan change which means a
massive
change to land use
and within this district
and an another item through
a water zone um
that a very rare kanuka stand an eel
13 hectares
has been bought by doc and the ims
immediate steps funding operated through
the water zone
has a granted ten ten thousand and six
dollars
for weed and pest control um this is
quite significant this is a
the dry land um ecosystem
of the plains is just about gone
and this is a significant stand right in
the middle of a dairy farm which is
getting irrigated but has still managed
to
um to
remain and docker sport it and it will
be
enhanced and the other issue
which will be of interest to the rural
drainage groups
and i sefton has got one that
he can always got three actually that he
can
still um administers and the district
council has
five others the um
under the uh nps and the nes rules
a natural wetland has protection
um under these nes
rules and we're having this is
becoming clear to members farming
people that around the rural drainage
groups
if your land has a natural wetland on it
as
identified by ecan and it's gone across
the district and done
aerial aerial mapping at this point
which it
which it wants to get onto people's
lands in to
verify by examining the land itself
there is to be no drainage work within
100 metres
of that wetland
the this was a subject
uh last week to extensive discussion at
the central
rural drainage group whereby we had
landowners
who have aerial mapping of it
wetlands and are reluctant to let ecan
onto
their land to verify that
this is a wetland um and
as a consequence if
if there isn't any ground what they call
ground truthing of
the aerial mapping the aerial mapping
stands
and the waimakuri district council
is is required to give a
100 metres buff around this area and
it's many
hectares in on many farms
particularly down line side road as you
can imagine
if you know the lower part of landside
road
so this has again significant
implications for
the district and how drainage of the
district
may or may not be able to
continue so at the moment
why mccary district council staff are
talking to
ekeen staff to get a common
understanding on how this will go
forward
bearing in mind that this nes has only
come into force at september the third
so um again significant implications
um for the district and the the and the
farming of this district
um the impetus behind the
nes is to protect the
well the prevent the further loss of any
wetland
and if you do have a wetland on your
property is to
stop your farming of it
where it interferes with the hydrology
of the wetland and the ecology of it
so interesting times ahead
thank you for that right item 11
consultation projects underway we've got
the natural hazards one
is still going with closes on october
the 19th the
significance and engagement policy
[Music]
wood end walking and cycling
improvements so they had
a drop-in session last week
public accession so that closes on the
22nd of october
right board funding update we didn't
spend any money tonight so that says
stands
media anything anybody would like me to
highlight
figure something out no questions
understanding orders
and no general business understanding
orders
so close that part of the meeting and
say thank you very much
you